that show that you did with Paulie and
Tom green I was supposed to do it we
yeah
were you guys mad actually I was a
little mad because I felt like you left
at the last second and then Paulie told
me that you got a commercial and I ain't
seen no commercial yet so as soon as he
said it and you can correct me I felt
like it was [ __ ] but maybe it wasn't
was a [ __ ] no you got that Jane
Lynch yeah yeah it was real it was
wonderful but never was okay so if
anyone's listening right now I was
supposed to do a show yeah with Pauly
Shore Harland and Tom Green and Illinois
in a look yeah Illinois and I was upset
because I I just knew we'd have so much
fun I know he to his bum I wanted to do
it but then Jordan Peele called me days
before and says hey I'm doing this
commercial with chelsea peretti and I
want you and Jane Lynch in it and he how
much it was and it couldn't let it down
yeah so then I was just like I had to
choose between bad dude I knew that you
guys would be mad at me well I was
suspicious because the timing it was
like literally we were all gonna do it
the night before we got to the airport
yeah he Pauline Tom Green where they
were like where's Bobby and Paulie goes
oh bobby got a commercial and I want
[ __ ] like last night at midnight he
got a commercial so I just thought you
just weren't into it but you wanted to
probably get he knew days before he
didn't tell well then you can see why I
thought it was you know but I I'm glad
to hear it was real how are the shows
were the fun it was great we are such a
good time yeah really fun Paulie was
great tom was great well it was like a
road trip right because we had we drove
to three different cities and we did a
new theater every night yeah so it was
like the three of us stopped them for
fast food I'm driving and getting hotels
and avant dinner it was really fun we
really missed you a lot of people were
like after the show we did a VIP
meet-and-greet
so many people like where the hell's
Bobby like you or you were really miss
maybe we can do it again one day would
you do it again of course thought this
time I'll show up yeah I would longer
and by the way I understand if any of us
got a high-paying commercial we would go
to yeah yeah no I'd you told me that cuz
that that wasn't my head a little bit
thank you we're clearing now how long is
it I thought it was [ __ ] on me so
I'm glad you told me
yeah but there's another thing it's like
the intro thing grievance dry beautiful
I know but the thing is is that you've
wanted to tell me to call you you know
and you never said anything but I almost
didn't know this [ __ ] thing comes
around yeah like you didn't say you know
anything else you want to get out no
what I'm saying is that you have I hate
blue Underpants now I know that's all we
got that's see you out you said earlier
about being friends that's what makes up
friendship we have the beautiful fudgy
movie we had the omelet in the anthill
we had the misunderstanding about the
intro who had you lying about a
commercial and these are the elements
that the ups and downs that create a
mold a beautiful friendship you
underpants yeah so we're good boy good
boy
yeah oh there's another funny thing that
you've been doing when I when I break
you uh-huh what do you say I say okay I
do a show right yeah I bring Harlan all
right he doesn't think that I do this
but I sit right down in the back oh you
do and I watch him
oh what do you say about me as Bobby's
leaving I go how about a half for my son
isn't he great
he's pre-op he's gonna be a girl
yeah and sometimes I go who wants to pop
my daughter's okay yeah do you hear me
laughing I always love it you know I
think I've heard you laugh at couples
but I always thought you were just
laughing because you were on the way out
I didn't know you sat down
no I sit down in the back just here at
you I love it thank you
yeah you just bow in Asian way it was
Cambodia oh I see oh yeah the arch and
stuff yeah yeah what are we doing we're
about an hour oh wow
[Music]